gonna get you a quick review gotta edit
it upload it hopefully sleep before I
drive to a friend's house it's about
three hours away you know to hang out
and [__]
so expend four Bulls is the fourth
Expendables film that's right nearly 10
years after the last Expendables
Adventure they're back for one final
Adventure until the next final Adventure
this movie stars Jason Statham who's
gone a bit Rogue Megan Fox is leading
the Expendables point of Stallone isn't
even in the movie that much and most of
the rest of the Expendables crew looks
like they're like well I wish I shared
that luxury because for the most part
they all look bored to be fair to them
this movie is mostly boring of The
Expendables crew Jason Statham's the one
that exhibits any sort of scream
presence or Charisma rest of the crew
feels like they're here out of some sort
of contractual obligation even the great
Andy Garcia can't save this thing feels
like he's doing a favor for a friend but
he's pissed because he's missing happy
hour or something he just feels like he
doesn't want to be there which is a real
bummer there are a couple moments where
you can see the concept of this film
being a Cheesy low budget straight to
Sci-fi channel Grade B action flick just
stuffing our faces while we're watching
it you can see in moments where that
would have worked if the groundwork
wasn't already set up up to groundwork
being ineptitude making a Grade B film
that leans into its cheese but that's
the cool part about it it's actually
harder to do than people think if you
pull it off great audiences can have
themselves a fun party film if you don't
pull it off you can come across as
awkward if not embarrassing going
forward I feel like Expendables should
pull it back from now on just make
Expendables Tony jaw and Jason Statham
and they're going around kicking ass the
rest of the Expendables crew they were
oh what's the word
sure there's a word to describe them
that very well could be a title of a
film the gunshots the hits they were
actually pretty satisfying in that
Bloody splattery kind of way you know
I've been playing Mortal Kombat 1
recently just kind of tracked for my
week fit right in uh the hand-to-hand
combat stay with me on this uh when it's
not the Legends at work not good the
camera was far too close to the action
there was way too much shaky cam
probably because they're trying to write
checks these bodies can't cash Eco Weiss
has the best fight in the film that's
why there's already a clip of it on
YouTube before the film even came out
again there's the marketing telling you
that's what the fights are going to look
like in here but they don't however you
can tell he's holding back he's never
able to push it to a hundred it's like
seeing a badass sports car on the road
but during bumper-to-bumper traffic so
Tony John Eco are no joke but you still
need camera work that can capture it and
co-stars who can keep up I feel like
they were at a disadvantage even being
in here you can have martial arts
Legends in your new Expendables film but
if you don't properly utilize them
what's the point and the green screen
was completely noticeable absolute ass
however again only about 90 minutes long
I can appreciate that those like
Expendables has lost the point that
breathed it into existence in the first
place get as many action stars of
yesteryear on screen together in an
action film that celebrates the genre
and decade that made them this just
feels like Dollar Store Fast and Furious
which is funny because Fast and Furious
kinda feels like Expendables so we're
dealing with the chicken in the egg
scenario now and the very end of the
film is
I laughed was it supposed to be funny
again I'm not sure it felt like a Family
Guy joke like Stewie's gonna be like he
is yes well nobody really pays attention
to height but in the end I'm not gonna
remember this one in T minus one day
yeah get the [__] out of here all right
so Expendables four have you seen it
what did you think about it what's your
favorite action film or celebration of
action film that this movie might have
tried to be but definitely did not stick
the landing on whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]